Pronto, o filme, de facto, dá uma sensação de calma.
Mas depois põe-nos em diversas situações em que quando nós entramos numa floresta, obviamente umas árvores muito elevadas, muito grandes, eu fiquei com uma sensação, não é bem assustadora, mas é de claustrofobia.
E depois as árvores ficam lá em cima e nós ficamos no chão.
ou seja, muito pequenino, e penso que é uma certa falta de ar.
Entretanto, saímos daí e, outra vez, ar, mar, montanhas ao fundo, portanto, é a parte que eu mais gosto.
Portanto, essa sensação...
obrigou-me a ir lá acima e depois vim cá abaixo e depois pude ir para cima.
Mas a música ajuda a que nós mantenhamos calmas.
Eu sou muito ansiosa e, portanto, continuo com a minha realidade, não é?
Mas naquele bocadinho eu gostei de ver o filme, achei interessante.
Eu achei que psicologicamente pode ajudar.
Mas o filme é interessante.
Está bem feito, a música está muito bem escolhida e leva-nos, de facto, a várias sensações.
Essa parte, por exemplo, das flores e das árvores, não gostei, porque senti uma certa falta de ar.
Depois a coisa acalma e voltamos, outra vez, ao melhor.
A mais espaço e mais visão e mais mar.